numbers numbers
numbers numbers numbers numbers numbers
uh
numbers yeah yeah
you're ready to learn one
two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
yeah yeah let's do it one more get one
two three four five six seven
eight nine ten get yeah
y'all ready for some more y'all ready
for some more young kids ready for some
more
let's go 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20
20 what
robots i don't know
[Music]
two robots three robots
full robots five robots
[Music]
11 robots 12 robots
15 roblox 16 robots
17 roblox
[Music]
now let's go backwards ten
nine eight seven six five four
three two one ten
nine eight seven six five four
three two one two three four five
[Music]
kids congratulations i'm really proud
of you you are catching on
so fast and i i i know
this is just the beginning this is just
the beginning and we
we did one through ten one two three
four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven through
twenty
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen seventeen eighteen nineteen
twenty but that's just the beginning
that's just the beginning there's so
much more
there's so much more let's go
21 22 23 24
25 26 27 28
29 30. yeah yeah
30 30 21 22 23
24 25 26 27 28 29
30 30 21 22 23
24 25 26 27 28 29
30 30 30.
[Music]
that's enough for today that's class is
over for today kids
but you got a long life ahead of you
yeah one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one uh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten yeah
ten nine eight seven six ten nine eight
seven six
ten nine eight seven six ten nine eight
seven six
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one
[Music]
that's all i got
[Music]
you're a kid so you gonna watch this one
over and over and over
so i see you back
[Music]
that baby don't know how to run this
back running back for it for the
seven eight nine kids ten nine eight
seven six five four three two one